No further
My generals. In killing my wife
Humanity has proven to me that they don't deserve the earth. We will scour them off the land
My father, he's gone mad
And now he's going to destroy the world
He will #### and betray
They all must die
Imaging it
A world without humans
Under endless night
My god. Dracula has to be destroyed we can't fail
*Stomg dard*
They're all gonna die. All of them!
Enough
Hey everybody its Charlie
They finally dropped a proper trailer for Castlevania Season 2 so we gotta break it down if you're brand new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos. There's actually a lot of really cool stuff coming up from Netflix
Anime is kind of their secret weapon now, but they're also working on that new witcher TV series
But they're not even gonna be shooting that till later this year and it'll probably take them another year to get it out
so it could be
2020 before we see that but if you're not familiar with the
Castlevania series the plot of this is based mostly on the plot of the Castlevania 3 game because it primarily follows
Trevor Belmont and his adventure to take down Dracula. Who's an
Ancestor to the original Simon Belmont from the beginning of the series. The project itself has a really interesting history
It started out as a movie when that fell through they decided to turn it into a TV series
So that's why season 1 is only four episodes because that's basically the movie that they expand it a little bit and they just dropped
It on Netflix as a series then because it turned out so awesome and people liked it so much
They renewed it for season 2 but doubled the order so season 2 is 8 episodes much closer to a proper series
But the events of season 1 are mostly
Dracula meeting his wife
Them having Alucard in him trying to live life as a normal human like she inspires him to be a better person because there's this
Little prequel where she finds him at the beginning of the series enters his castle seeking knowledge to become a healer
He just completely flabbergasted. It ends up falling in love with her
I've known you two minutes and you offer for me to walk the earth like an ordinary peasant
While I give you the knowledge of immortals the true science
They have Alucard but then later as he sort of traveling the land around the church
Burns her as a witch because part of the twist of season one is that the bishop is the real enemy
The church itself is kind of an antagonist but not the entire church just through this particular bishop
They don't throw them all under the bus, but as they're burning her at the stake
Some of the other church officials are questioning it like, you know, well, maybe she wasn't quite so bad
But the bishop played by matt free where his voice is very recognizable. It's just like nope
She's done burner burn at the stake. All of our problems are her fault. We'll burn her. It'll solve everything
So Dracula finds out in declares war on all of humanity starting with pilikia
So season one is him summoning the night horde in the beginning of their attack
Season two seems like there's a bit of a time jump and you get to meet all the generals
So the name of Dracula's army is the night horde. It's huge. It has its own generals its own power structure
You see some of the different beasts that they employ you see them tinkering with bodies infusing them with demonic energy
So there's just like a whole side of this that you didn't get with season one because it was only four episodes
The only real Knight horde characters that we meet are right at the end when Trevor is defeating these last
hellhounds and they speak to the bishop before they take him down and the rest of the town starts to burn to ashes it seems
Like Dracula's generals are collecting the bodies after that battle
So the beasts that they defeated in the finale were really just the beginning like that's what they say
We have an army. You have no idea how big the Horde is
And then they promptly fall into a Locard's tomb wake him up and form their alliance and then it just cuts to the credits
Between showing off Dracula's generals, they show a couple different encounters here like it opens on this snowy little town
It's them just travelling through
They probably just come upon some of the night horn
But you have to imagine that Dracula is just going from town to town
This much larger town looks a little bit like well lakeya
But it could be another town but the whole idea is that Dracula intends to wipe humanity from the entire earth
So it's just expanding from season 1 season 1 was largely contained to like one or two small towns
I tried to check the IMDB
They haven't officially announced who the voice cast is for these new characters playing Dracula's generals
But the animation is fantastic
This is actually a project from one of my former bosses Fred Seibert at Frederator
But they're a couple different Studios involved in producing this they already announced actually through Richard Armitage
I think without intending to that they were gonna do a season 3
It had been backed or renewed and they were gonna be recording stuff really soon
But this is mostly just because it takes so long to get animation this complex out there
Joke that one of the animators had that there are more lines in Trevor's mouth than in all of Steven universe's head
Which he tried to explain wasn't a dig on Steven universe. He wasn't trying to make fun of that series
This is that some animation is designed to be more simple. Some is more complex
Castlevania because of what they were doing with the series
Demanded more complex animation which itself is actually inspired by a symphony of the night
So the plot is mostly Castlevania three
But the design is mostly Symphony of the Night which as you can tell is fantastic
So there are only four episodes in season 1 if you have not watched it yet or you haven't watched the billion more times
I recommend checking it out the interesting thing about
Castlevania 3 if you haven't played it is that there are actually four separate endings to that game
So I'm interested to see how they incorporate that into the series
However, many seasons it winds up going for anime. Typically doesn't get that many episodes compared to traditional Western animations
so
Hopefully they'll make it to like four or five
Seasons at least but I'll be curious to see if they incorporate any of those four
Separate endings from the original game or if it's some sort of twist on that because yes, they do eventually defeat Dracula
Like that's the whole idea of the game is that you're supposed to be Dracula?
You crumble his castle, but there are so many
Castlevania games as part of the series that deal with Dracula as the antagonist
So you just wonder how they're gonna treat that in the Canon because eventually I think the idea is that Simon Belmont
hundreds of years later is born
He also fights Dracula
But I'm not expecting that to really be a big part of the series because travel Belmont will be the primary
Protagonist for however long this runs for so let me know in the comments
What you thought of season 1 what you think of this trailer so far?
The official premiere date is Halloween later this year, which seems appropriate
Netflix drop more Ironfist season 2 there was a whole bunch of Avenger stuff. There's more stuff left over from Comic Con
So I'll try to get through all the videos as fast as possible
Leave all your video requests in the comments below but click here to learn about that big Disney buy out of box
That went through yesterday and click here to rewatch the Dragon Ball super movie trailer. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight